[Música]
abraço a pessoa do outro lado
abraça pessoa do outro lado
ele acabou de abraçar alguém que não
conhecia ótimo
como é que obras alguém que a gente não
conhece a gente abraça na cara do palco
e foi abraçar se abraça mas é menos
confortável né meu protocolarmente
platinum bracinho está sem entender o
que está acontecendo agora imagina que
um estádio um imagina que isso aqui é é
uma arquibancada de futebol prorrogação
nosso time acabou de marcar o gol do
título não sei nem ver quem está do
outro lado se pega pelo pescoço sem
grita e tá tudo bem porque o futebol faz
isso com a gente
o futebol permite que a gente faça
coisas que a gente não tá acostumado
fazer coisas que a gente não se permite
nosso dia a dia dentro de um mesmo
espectro diria que para o bem e para o
mal
no futebol dentro de um estádio ou
qualquer coisa que circula o óbito do
futebol a gente levar as coisas que a
gente enquanto sociedade já aprendeu que
não são certas que são abomináveis
a gente vê a gente vê machismo a gente
vê racismo a gente vê homofobia a gente
vê sexismo
mas nesse mesmo espectro do outro lado a
gente também se permite isso a gente
permitir aprovado dá um [ __ ] braço uma
pessoa que a gente nunca viu antes
e naquele momento aquela pessoa a pessoa
mais importante do mundo pra gente
futebol para mim é que isso é que essa
luta que a gente coloca na sociedade
tudo que a gente faz ea gente perder
essa lente de aumento e aí a gente
consegue enxergar coisas que talvez a
gente não se permita enxergar o fazer
quando a gente está no nosso dia a dia
tem uma obra da década de 30 um livro
chamado bolo dems o autor ele propõe que
os jogos que tipo de jogo não só o
futebol não só não só os esportes mas os
jogos eles são intervalos na nossa vida
e aí nesses intervalos a gente propõe um
conjunto de regras específicas e esses
conjuntos de regras nesse intervalo
provocam tensão a gente fica tenso né
gente quanto desconfortável e não sabe o
que aconteceu
isso é muito louco gente pensar nisso no
futebol porque o tamanho da abstração
que esse negócio chega não é a gente
está jogando tem 22 pessoas jogando ali
ea gente tá tem sua gente tem certo
sobre o que vai acontecer
então a gente pega uma lógica que
funciona para qualquer jogo ea gente
está em um ponto que pode leva isso para
uma potencialidade que não faria sentido
para tentar vê sentido isso eu vou
correr um risco enorme posso falar uma
grande
besteira mas eu vou tomar emprestado um
conceito da da psicanálise que o
conceito de sentimento oceânico sendo
muito raso mas floyd meio que tentava
explicar a religiosidade com base nesse
conceito dizendo que quando a gente é
muito pequenininho logo a gente acabou
de nascer e tal a gente que entende a
gente tem noção corporal a gente não
sabe o que é o meu corpo que é o todo
que o mundo acha que mesmo que tudo é
tudo uma coisa só eu sou tudo sou eu
e aí o resquício zinho disso na nossa
vida adulta eventualmente explicaria a
fé de algumas pessoas essa essa ligação
que algumas pessoas têm com alguma coisa
maior
e é esse risco é quase que essa licença
poética de empréstimo que eu tô tomando
que eu gostaria de trazer pro futebol eu
acho que o que acaba acontecendo quando
a gente está num estágio é muito próximo
do que acaba acontecendo dentro de uma
igreja essa relação entre as pessoas
essa relação como entidade e isso
eventualmente traz uma hipérbole porque
para os nossos comportamentos
uma vez que a gente entende porque o
futebol é grande que o futebol é
importante que o futebol consegue
mostrar pra gente várias coisinhas que a
gente faz a nossa vida num sentido
extremo eu acho que a gente pode começar
a tentar usar um pouquinho de tecnologia
para entender os comportamentos da
sociedade tendo o futebol como como esse
pano de fundo e dentro dessa tecnologia
na tecnologia de jogo de campo não
levaram essas coisas a tecnologia do que
importa dos milhões de pessoas que estão
em volta dos 22 jogando
e aí eu peguei e dentro dessa tecnologia
toda eu peguei uma coisa que eu acredito
bastante que são os dados e desses dados
e fez um recorte zinho do tipo de dado
que eu uso muito que eu gosto muito
são os dados dos comportamentos de busca
no google porque eu acho que as pessoas
não mentem para o google que alguém
mente para o google realmente provou que
acontece mas é um resultado que não
queria então ninguém ganha com isso pra
gente um link para o google gente
honesta o google então promessa que
todos os dados que o gol depois
disponibilize seja um sejam harmonizados
sejam agregados sejam coletivizados eles
conseguem ajudar a gente traz algumas
linhas de comportamentos sociais e é
isso que eu queria contar um pouquinho
pra vocês
então por exemplo esse aqui é o
comportamento de é o interesse de
comportamento de buscas dos
norte-americanos estados unidos 2004 até
aqui pelo basquete
foi assim que eu comecei a pesquisa eu
limpar esse negócio falei [ __ ] incrível
gráfico bonito ele sobe e desce e sobe e
desce temos unidade bem definido consigo
talvez até te ver o que vai acontecer
depois
aí eu pensei bom será que o basquete
será que o americano que será que tá
acontecendo eu fiz um outro teste e fui
ver o que está acontecendo com o futebol
americano nos estados unidos
eu vi a mesma coisa o gráfico sobe desce
tem uma sazonalidade bem definida dá até
para arriscar um palpite vizinho do que
aconteceu ele pra frente
falei agora eu pegar esse dado jogar
futebol no brasil vai dar um dado
bonitinho eu vou fazer uma curta
apresentação vou prever o futuro a
galera vai se acostumar e inteligente só
que aí eu cheguei neste gráfico aqui
esse é o interesse de busca do futebol
do brasileiro 2004 até aqui um pouco
mais caótico um pouco mais anárquico tão
caótico anárquico imprevisível quanto o
próprio futebol em si tem vários estudos
falam sobre isso um deles foi feito na
no instituto nacional de los álamos
laboratório nacional de los alamos novo
méxico e eles pegaram mais de 300 mil
partidas de vários esportes coletivos e
eles chegaram à conclusão de que a gente
não sabe dentro do consolidado no
futebol era o mais imprevisível de todos
eles e aí isso começa a fazer sentido
quando a gente pensa que lá no luís
quando a gente pensa na tensão quando a
gente pensa na incerteza e que isso dá
graça pro jogo então justamente essa
anarquia esse caos fazem do futebol o
esporte mais popular do mundo
então eu fiz uma comparação interessante
de buscas do futebol com alguns outros
esportes
eu tenho aqui o basquete tem o futebol
americano o tênis e no críquete que é um
esporte bastante popular muito popular
em países de colonização britânica ea
gente vê o futebol com uma vantagem
considerável em relação a todos eles e
aí tem um momento a cada quatro anos em
que a gente celebra o maior esporte do
mundo copa do mundo eu fui entender se a
celebração principal do nosso esporte
preferido também é tão grande quanto o
próprio futebol
e aí eu cheguei neste gráfico aqui que
eu tenho a copa do mundo em azul tem ali
o amarelinho que o super boca
praticamente pro forma para a gente
mostrar o tamanho das proporções das
coisas e eu tenho o vermelho que são as
olimpíadas e é muito legal a gente vê
que as olimpíadas na época a cada dois
anos porque são as de verão e de inverno
mas é muito interessante a gente vê que
a celebração do futebol é maior do que a
celebração de todos os outros esportes
juntos inclusive do futebol
mas como é só o futebol a gente torna
esse negócio um pouquinho maior a gente
dá um pouquinho mais interesse para ele
e ele teve um momento que até quem não
gosta de futebol estava muito março
nisso eu acho que a copa do mundo não
tem como todo mundo tem como comprar um
pão sem falar sobre isso mas teve um
momento em que mesmo quem odeia futebol
e se tranca numa caverna durante a copa
do mundo falou muito sobre isso e estou
bastante foi com a copa do mundo veio
visitar gente aqui em 2014 e em 2014 dos
mais de 2.262 de buscas que fizeram
sobre o tema nesse período a gente
consegue entender algumas coisas do
comportamento algumas coisas do que de
fato estava guiando as pessoas naquele
momento por exemplo a argentina
argentina é um país que leva um futebol
bastante a sério
gostam de futebol e levam a sério mas
assim que acabou a cerimônia de abertura
da copa as buscas pela derrota foram
cinco vezes maiores do que pelo messi
a gente fala pô eles estavam levando até
mesmo um futebol tão a sério quanto a
gente acha que a gente tanta gente aqui
no brasil estava levando né
na verdade a gente também não a gente
vai procurando mais pelo cabelo loiro do
neymar do que pelo cartão amarelo que
ele tomou
quem tava levando o futebol a sério
surpreendentemente os estados unidos
quando começa o jogo entre alemanha e
estados unidos
as buscas pela seleção norte americana
foram maiores do que por qualquer outro
termo não só dentro do esporte não só
qualquer outro termo
naquele momento o país que é um dos
poucos países que não há país do futebol
virou o país do futebol
esse negócio como eles estão eles jeito
também acaba a primeira fase começa a
segunda fase e gente começa a entender
que estava preocupado com que os
argentinos por exemplo que eles estão
preocupados com o brasil não estão
preocupados em cheio o nosso saco
a musiquinha brasil decidiu que senta lá
na argentina tava tendo mais buscas do
que o neymar ele estavam mais
preocupados e vim aqui cantar música é
duas vezes mais preocupado em vir aqui
cantar musiquinha do que preocupados com
neymar a recíproca não é verdadeira a
gente estava preocupado com a argentina
quartas de final a gente tava procurando
três vezes mais pela argentina do que
pela colômbia que esse é o nosso próximo
adversário e tinha um terceiro fator
importante uma terceira uma terceira
seleção importante na copa de 2014 em
natal da alemanha
com quem ela estava preocupada brasil na
argentina na alemanha estavam
preocupados em como eliminar olheiras
cinco vezes no crescimento de busca
porque o fuso horário deles não estava
ajudando acontece a gente joga vem a
alemanha sem olheiras 71 e aí o davi
falou 71 ele podia ter falado disso né
amigo tabu a gente não falar dos 71 mas
na verdade quando a gente olha para os
dados a gente vê que os 71 foi menos
traumático do que a gente fez parecer
todo que a gente contou para as pessoas
que estava acontecendo quando o brasil
para o jogo com a alemanha a gente ao
invés de né meu deus mundo acabou e eu
não gosto mais de futebol não quero nem
saber sobre a copa pelo contrário quero
saber sobre a copa mas eu não quero mais
saber sobre sobre o brasil
a gente começou se preocupar com a
decisão de terceiro lugar estão
procurando três vezes mais pelos lugares
onde se a decisão do terceiro lugar do
que pela final da copa
aí a gente foi decidir o terceiro lugar
ea gente perder de novo
acabou a gota d'água pelo amor de deus
não tem mais o que fazer não brasileiro
otimista resiliente
a gente começou a procurar duas vezes
mais pela cópia pela copa de 2018 do que
pela final entre entre alemanha e
argentina
só que independentemente do quão
resiliente e resiliente do continuísmo a
gente a perder a final ea gente não
estava preocupada com ninguém mesmo
antes do jogo as buscas na argentina
estouraram subiram mais de 20 vezes por
feriado
aí começa o jogo quem é o adversário a
alemanha que tinha acabado de me ter
sete no brasil
e aí é um problema e aí só tinha uma
pessoa que podia ajudar gente naquele
momento deus e eles tentarão as buscas
pelo pai nosso foram 66 vezes maiores
sessenta e seis vezes maiores do que
pela música da copa era musiquinha até
semana e não deu certo não foi deus deu
alemanha aconteceu a alemanha mas teve
uma coisa que eu tive que dar o braço a
torcer e essa estava muito seguro de que
não ia acontecer mas os dados não
pegaram uma pecinha aquela musiquinha
que eles estão procurando mais o que o
neymar com o brasil e chineses entre ela
acaba com a mensagem muito clara
a dor é maior que pela lei nunca vai
acontecer mas eu fui dar uma olhada nos
dados e esse aqui é o comportamento de
buscas em 2014 na hora da copa no mundo
inteiro e interesse por maradona em azul
e pela em vermelho
de fato o maradona no mundo era um
pouquinho maior que o pela pelo menos no
comportamento de buscas em futebol a
gente entra entre outro mérito e agora
aqui metade de vocês já me odeia tanto a
metade também é 71 maradona maior que
pelé já perdi você completamente entrar
em polêmica
polêmica no futebol brasileiro maior
torcida as pesquisas dizem pra gente que
é a maior torcida do brasil é do
flamengo e do corinthians seria a
segunda maior torcida existe uma teoria
por trás disso de que na década de 80
televisão aberta é mostrava muitos jogos
do fundo do rio como um todo para outros
próprias regiões
o flamengo tinha um timaço ganhou da
torcida e tal então segundo essa teoria
a gente tenha uma torcida do corinthians
concentrada e uma torcida do flamengo
mais pulverizada
fui lá para os dados e fui entender como
as pessoas estavam buscando por isso e
aparentemente a coisa tava a teoria meio
que se confirma esses dois dados o
flamengo em vermelho e o corinthians em
azul esses dois graus dois mapas eles
mostram o interesse proporcional do
total de buscas feitas no lugar com a
proporcionalidade de interesse em cada
um dos estados ea gente vê inclusive que
o amapá e maranhão têm um interesse
proporcional maior até do que o do rio
de janeiro enquanto do corinthians
a gente tem um interesse muito
concentrado em são paulo se a gente
olhar para essas barrinhas aqui embaixo
a gente vê que os em 100 do meu
balizador máximo sendo ele o teto maior
interesse eu vou ter o corinthians com o
segundo o segundo colocado mato grosso
do sul já com 70 no flamengo para chegar
aos 70 eu tenho que ir até o décimo
colocado que já em roraima
então de fato eu tenho uma torcida super
concentrado em são paulo no caso do
corinthians uma torcida super
pulverizada bastante centralizado no
caso do flamengo o que ajuda a confirmar
um pouquinho da nossa teoria dada a
distribuição de torcidas mas o
corinthians é muito grande
é muito grande
e pra falar do corinthians muito grande
talvez vale trazer um dos corintianos
mais ilustres da história talvez um dos
maiores esportistas do brasil ao doleiro
funciona
e aí quando eu pego nos últimos anos de
interesse de busca pelo cena no brasil
aqui a gente deve ter uns três quatro
anos a gente vê que tem um pico sempre
em 1º de maio o aniversário de morte
dele e aí o do ano passado a gente tem
um pico um pouquinho maior do que os
anos os anos anteriores mas logo na
seqüência a gente tem ali no final um
pico que a gente vê que não completa um
ano este pico está no comecinho de
outubro que o senhor fez no começo de
outubro especificamente nessa data que
teria esse pico o senado mas o
corinthians fez o lançamento da camisa 3
do corinthians homenageando santana
então se a gente olhar preciso últimos
anos a gente vê que esse dia
especificamente esse lançamento de
camisa fez mais gente se interessar pelo
cena do que as coisas que você não fez
na vida do tipo é o aniversário de morte
dele e esse ano agora 2019 a gente
completou 20 anos da morte do cena então
é uma coisa que mexeu com bastante gente
e 2009 por si só já foi um ano meio
esquisito foi um ano que já começou a
gente já viu que começou esquisito que o
problema tivesse a noção de que essa
coisa meio estranha quando a gente teve
o rompimento da barragem de brumadinho
esse é o interesse de buscas um ano por
brumadinho e aí com uma barragem virar
notícia tem esse pico todo e quando
acontece esse pique de sobra pra mim
falar da vida do amor de deus por minha
vontade é pequenininha muito pouca gente
conhecia brumadinho é lógico que eu vou
ter um pico porque a minha base inicial
era muito baixo
a gente vê esse pico é relevante ou não
talvez vale colocar um balizador vai
colocar um outro um outro elemento que a
gente saiba o tamanho da grandeza dele e
para trazer esse outro elemento vale
pensar no que aconteceu pouquíssimos
dias depois do rompimento da barragem de
brumadinho
quando a gente teve um incêndio no
alojamento das categorias de base do
flamengo e essa é a comparação entre
brumadinho e flamengo flamengo como um
todo
não não somente está o acidente ea gente
vê que o mágico de fato teve um pico mas
o flamengo logo na sequência quase se
iguala mas o que é mais interessante é
estável ele começa de um
feito e ele oscila mas ele oscila
praticamente dentro de uma mesma de uma
mesma média a gente isolar o flamengo
aqui eu não consigo dizer pra vocês
quando a gente teve um acidente
seríssimo que matou os jovens e quando
teve um clássico um jogo importante
talvez no final de campeonato
isso me traz pra um para uma máxima já
bastante difundida que é de que futebol
é a coisa mais importante entre as menos
importantes
e pra gente nunca deixar essa balança
acaba pendendo para o lado em que não
deveria não só pelo futebol mas para
qualquer uma das coisas importantes que
a gente deveria estar olhando eu acho
muito que a gente pode sim se apóia em
dados se apoiar em tecnologia porque há
grande coisa é que os dados não só
aquela coisa fria aquela coisa distante
aquela coisa e inatingível que ninguém
pode ter essa tudo que mostrei pra vocês
são dados públicos um dado qualquer um
podia ter feito essa apresentação
qualquer um de vocês aqui podia ter
feito essa apresentação que os dados
eles são acessíveis os dados estão aqui
para ajudar a gente e eles não servem
para curar aquela angústia que a gente
tem de do incerto do futuro porque dado
não é sobre prever o futuro mas dado
para a gente conseguir entender com
granularidade a complexidade das
relações entre as pessoas e isso ajuda a
gente a tomar decisões melhores em
qualquer âmbito no âmbito da
administração pública no âmbito dos
negócios no âmbito das nossas relações
interpessoais no âmbito da vida e claro
no âmbito do futebol
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]